[Musique]
Émilie Nicolas Michel COG Christian
Dufour bonsoir
bonsoir ça nous a beaucoup étonné quand
Patrick Pichette nous raconte qu'il y a
pas eu de Legends il n'a pas demandé
tous les livres c'est quand même
incroyable cette histoire on assiste les
gens vont dire là chez nous avec Twitter
monsieur roi mais c'est quand même sur
la scène internationale dans ce genre de
réseau sociaux c'est intéressant de
suivre ce qui se passe bon
le masque qu'en pensez-vous mais avant
réfléchissez je vous fais entendre c'est
pas gagné d'avance Paris là on écoute
travaille beaucoup que les gens je
travaille dans des espaces clos je
ressens pas de besoin de le porter parce
que le monde fait que non moi je pense
que c'est chacun va prendre ses
responsabilités et moi personnellement
j'ai pas envie de le porter j'ai pas
envie d'être obligé de le porter je
pense que les gens qui veulent qui sont
dans la même situation devrait pas être
obligé
bon je rappelle personne est obligé mais
on recommande fortement dans les lieux
publics
achalander comme on dit Émilie Nicolas
on verra quoi est-ce que les gens vont
accepter ou non
ouais mais c'est sûr que dans les
provinces où ça on est déjà fait
quelques jours d'avance là au niveau des
recommandations provinciales on voit que
le port du masque a augmenté beaucoup
dans les lieux publics par exemple en
Ontario dans les derniers jours
ceci dit le Québec est une des provinces
sous quand on voit les sondages il y
avait déjà un peu moins d'appui au
retour du port du masque de manière
générale
donc mais ça reste ça reste assez fort
donc on va voir ce que les gens vont
faire je pense que surtout si on
commence à avoir vraiment l'impact dans
les hôpitaux aussi les gens voient
comment ça déborde surtout les hôpitaux
pour enfants je pense que je pense que
les gens vont réaliser que c'est réel ce
qui se passe en ce moment puis que les
gens vont s'aiment de santé ont besoin
d'un coup de main essentiellement pour
passer à travers de ça puisque si on
peut aider à ce que les urgences écoute
soit pas pleines à 200% mais c'est c'est
la moindre des choses de faire notre
part mais je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui sont un peu dans dînés de cette
réalité là dans les hôpitaux si
eux-mêmes sont pas malades ils n'ont pas
des proches qui sont malades en ce
moment
du loin des yeux loin du cœur Michel C
Emilia réseau sur ce point-là
c'est-à-dire que on peut pas se plaindre
que les hôpitaux marchent pas qu'on
attend trois urgence si on prend pas des
mesures soi-même quand on peut pour
essayer de limiter le plus possible
la situation de de
dans les urgences dans les hôpitaux je
dirais un moment donné c'est quand même
pas demandé la fin du monde aux gens que
de mettre un masque dans le transport en
commun dans un endroit fermé il y a
beaucoup de monde de plus en plus de
gens font je comprends que l'obligation
c'est toujours un peu lourd et je pense
pas que le gouvernement va vouloir aider
là mais la réalité c'est que on est
vraiment dans une crise dans les
hôpitaux un buveau chiffre en début
d'émission vous savez qu'un des urgences
les mieux gérer au Québec font du 150%
parce qu'il y a un problème et une façon
de d'aider à la résolution de ce
problème
mais cette porter le masque et le
ministre en conférence de presse ce
matin à 10 mais on parle pas des écoles
donc on veut pas rouvrir
des là où ça a été plus litigieux plus
controversé Christian on dirait des nous
si vous voulez si vous voulez pas tant
pis
des écoles des garderie mais ça a
toujours été un axe de l'action du
gouvernement Lego en masseur Center bah
évidemment la ligne rouge c'est est-ce
que c'est obligatoire ou pas c'est très
important cette ligne rouge là puis le
gouvernement ne veut pas la traverser
heureusement je pense pas que les
discours là sur il faut faire notre part
il faut être solidaire je pense pas que
c'est efficace du tout les Québécois ont
donné là-dedans tu vois la pandémie ils
ont été solidaire et on fait beaucoup
d'efforts la majorité des gens sont
reconnaissants au gouvernement le goût
de sa gestion globale de la pandémie
avec le recul beaucoup trouve qu'on
s'est allé trop loin qu'on a dérapé avec
le couvre-feu avec le passeport Center
il me semble que ce sur quoi il faut
miser parce que le masque c'est vrai
c'est important dans le masque une image
négative c'est très normal que c'est une
image négatif donc ce qu'il faut miser à
mon sens c'est sur le gros bon sens
c'est que si tu as une grippe tu as des
symptômes c'est le gros bon sens tu
portes un masque pour protéger les
autres si tu as la covid tu portes un
masque pour protéger les autres et moi
c'est cet axe là que je pousserais plus
que les beaux discours à la solidarité
ça là c'est usé je crois que les gens
sont très fermés mesure il faut que vous
occupiez du système de santé ça c'est
beaucoup moins efficace on est dans une
nouvelle époque moi c'est comme ça que
je le vois tu vois on est dans une
nouvelle aire là maintenant il y a des
virus on sait que ça peut être dangereux
le masque c'est pas juste négatif c'est
possible servez-vous de votre tête entre
autres quand la grippe ça va tu vois
quand tu sors tu portes le masque deux
qui se sont parlés très près un de
l'autre pas de masque ce Trudeau
monsieur chie le président chinois deux
fois de suite mon première fois il se
parle monsieur Trudeau son bureau
raconte un peu ce dont il a été question
mais ce truc doit arrêter
à l'offensive en disant ne vous occupez
pas de nos élections s'il vous plaît
président de la Chine aujourd'hui je
vous le remonte si vous l'avez manqué
tout à l'heure voici ce qui s'est passé
grâce à notre caméraman de l'équipe
canadienne bravo on écoute
[Musique]
on le voit c'est rare qu'on voit ça
c'est très rare qu'on voit ça il est
furieux le président chinois il dit
ouais laisse faire tes affaires de c'est
pas pareil chez vous te dis ce qu'on
avait dit puis tu l'as mal dit en plus
Émilie comment vous avez trouvé la
performance entre guillemets de Monsieur
Trudeau est-ce que c'est bon pour lui
ici comment vous voyez ça
mais c'est sûr que je pense que dans le
contexte actuel avoir de l'air de d'être
ferme avec le président chinois je pense
pas que ça soit nécessairement une
bavure politique à ce niveau là je pense
pour une partie des gens ceci dit je
pense que faut premièrement dire qu'il y
a quand même un changement de temps
quand il était question de négocier les
plaies la libération des deux mycose les
deux Canadiens qui étaient qui étaient
détenus en Chine pendant longtemps
on avait très peu d'informations
publiques sur ce qui se passait entre le
gouvernement canadien et le gouvernement
chinois au niveau des négociations donc
le fait que le gouvernement Trudeau en
ce moment disent en maintenant 50 ans de
parler publiquement de ce qu'on de nos
conversations avec le gouvernement
chinois c'était pas lequel en passé puis
je pense aussi que la manière dont le
président chier traite juste un Trudeau
c'est aussi peut-être une séquence de ce
qui s'est passé à ce moment-là où le
Canada était laissé essentiellement les
États-Unis prendre la direction le
Canada est souvent dans les dernières
années en train de dire que on va jouer
en équipe avec nos alliés et nos alliés
qui ont qui sont plus puissants que nous
essentiellement
donc je pense que une des conséquences
que de ça ça peut être que juste intrudo
soit vu comme un joueur mineur qui suit
les États-Unis qui suivent au Biden et
c'est peut-être aussi ce qui est
derrière la manière dont Justin Trudeau
semble avoir été traité par la
Présidente c'est que Michel sait hier on
s'est empressé du côté canadien de
raconter donc au journaliste comme
Monsieur Trudeau avait dénoncé les
possibles ingériens chinoises dans le
processus électoral et c'est ça qui a
choqué entre autres les Chinois et
est-il allé aussi loin avec lui avec les
journalistes on le saura jamais mais
Michel
de toute façon le climat entre le Canada
et la Chine est en venimé par un grand
nombre de choses le fait que par exemple
la Chine
financièrement des candidats aux
élections Canada ce qui est quand même
pas être détails
la fille du président de Huawei à cause
d'un mandat d'amener des États-Unis
dans les séquelles de ça actuellement
alors il faut pas s'attendre à ce que
Monsieur si qui vient d'avoir un mandat
un troisième mandat alors que la loi
chinoise disait qu'il devait s'en aller
au bout du deuxième donc amène large
c'est ainsi bon pour nécessairement être
content quand jeêtre Trudeau fait
communiquer sur la petite conversation
que lui avec lui
tout ça c'est des séquelles de de
moi et d'année de mauvaise traditions
plus loin il aurait pu être plus
critique parce que la chaîne est
multipliée en fait les incidents de non
respect de la souveraineté canadienne
c'est bien beau de tant d'autres schisme
mais il y a une limite même face à une
superpuissance comme la chute cela dit
c'est fascinant en fait c'est extrait là
parce que ça fait sortir un autre
élément qui est plus inquiétant pour le
Canada c'est à quel point ici d'une pile
de respect pas Justin Trudeau à la fin
quand j'étais un Trudeau parle là
Monsieur d'une pin le regarde même pas
il regarde même pas dans les je
comprends que notre premier ministre
c'est pas de sa faute ça a l'air d'un
enfant d'école physiquement ça c'est une
pince c'est frappant la différence mais
le président chinois ne respecte pas sur
le plan personnel le premier ministre du
Canada et ça c'est un problème qu'on a
ça s'ajoute à l'autre problème de fond
je pense qu'on voulait ce que je veux
dire c'est que entre les deux pays on a
des gros problèmes et le Canada dans son
droit de réagir il faut qu'on réagisse
mais malheureusement notre premier
ministre est pas respecté par le
président chinois
est-ce que on peut s'améliorer dans les
mois à venir mais là on est en train
d'élaborer notre politique vous avez la
Chine qui est une politique plus ferme
et de d'essayer diversité nos
importations mais bon c'est beaucoup de
mots ça Michel est-ce que ça peut dans
les faits ça va prendre du temps avant
de réparer tout seul
oui ça va prendre aussi des changements
en Chine machine agit de façon
internationale puis dans la région de
l'Asie en plus comme un Bolé on
construit des bases militaires en des
milieux de l'océan sur des îles
artificielles pour essayer d'avoir de
souveraineté sur des parties de la mère
de Chine du Sud etc etc etc il y a pas
beaucoup de pays asiatiques qui sont
très à l'aise avec la Chine on n'a pas à
l'être nos autres non plus en tout cas
on était pour puis on l'a vu dans le
regard effectivement c'était pas il
n'était pas effrayé mais en même temps
parler de la Chine une autre fois
Monsieur Trump hier
on va l'écouter c'est comme dans
l'annonce là la batterie qui va très
vite l'autre qui est là on a
l'impression qu'il y avait pas mis
toutes ces batteries dans le moteur on
l'écoute on revient
[Applaudissements]
il a donc annoncé sa candidature à la
présidentielle pour 20-24 Christian tour
de table je sais pas si vous avez
l'occasion de regarder ça j'imagine
c'est c'était pas le même Donald Trump
qu'on a connu il y a même quelques
semaines clairement parce que il y a
quand même un espèce d'échec quelque
part dans les élections mi-manda pour
Donald Trump depuis le vent dans les
voiles on le sent il y a plus un
momentum comme tel il y avait l'air
quasiment un peu abattu peut aussi au
sein du parti républicain il y a des
prétendants qui se manifestent monsieur
de santismes Monsieur pince donc il faut
pas sous-estimer 30 on s'entend aussi il
est pas nouveau donc pour ceux qui
l'aiment pas
c'est une bonne nouvelle il me semble
que ces chances en fait d'être élu
président dans deux ans sont beaucoup
moins importantes qu'elles étaient et
c'est une bonne chose parce que
lorsqu'il était Président l'état du
monde était moins inquiétant qu'il est
devenu aujourd'hui donc citron per élu
dans deux ans avec le monde qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui là il y aurait quoi
être vraiment très je pense que tout le
monde le
sentiment
Émilie Émilie mais il veut aller au bout
d'une certaine démarche pour l'instant
pour l'instant voyons voir
jamais vraiment été capable de mettre la
défaite en
lorsqu'il a perdu l'élection 2020 donc
moi la question que je me pose c'est
est-ce qu'il serait capable d'admettre
la défaite c'est par l'investiture à la
présidence donc des
républicains je pense que c'est ça une
des questions qui qui se pose aussi dans
notre chambre remporte pas si la santé
sur quelqu'un d'autre apporte de bien
candidat à la présidence pour les
républicains qu'est-ce que dans notre
chambre à faire si surtout s'il est pas
empêché de de de de porter sa
candidature pour des raisons légales
qu'est-ce qui va répondre comme comme
mensonge sur ses adversaires qu'est-ce
qui va dire à sa base c'est toutes les
questions qui qui sont importantes à
sauver en ce moment on n'a pas vu encore
les limites de l'homme surtout lorsqu'il
refuse de perdre Michel c'est ouais et
ça ça produirait un schisme en tout cas
un autre sous-groupe Michel comment vous
avez trouvé ça hier
il y a des gens qui voulaient quitter la
salle c'était partisans sauf que les
gens de la sécurité empêchent de sortir
pour la fin du discours
comme ça
mais moi je pense qu'il s'est acheté de
l'assurance vie essentiellement il est
sous le coup de deux
criminels importants pour avoir essayé
de changer le résultat jour J de la
dernière élection et aussi sur les
erreurs du 6 du 16 janvier il essaie de
il essaie d'embarrasser le ministère de
la Justice pour que le ministère de la
Justice si jamais il porte des
accusations lui va dire c'est le
ministère politique dedans de Joe Biden
et c'est pour ça qu'il m'a qui m'a
poursuivent et bien sûr très intéressant
merci beaucoup à vous trois bonnes
soirées à très bientôt au revoir merci
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI